because of the war and the rise of
fascism you were prevented as a Jew from
working in universities or practicing
medicine so you had to set up a
laboratory on your own happy
well I gotta first to go out I went to
Bill said to her but then it was very
close to the beginning of the war and I
did not want to be a way of distance
from my family so I came back to LA to
do renata wrong and made a very small
levers are in my bedroom a very very
small room to separate walls had been in
my head migrated to Z to Brewster
came back and became my assistant I
first it was of course a system which
then worked okay sir and then I met the
first discovery of the program cell
death before is to go so everything was
enthusiastic approve tree the sister
design our system in chick embryo and
this was a excellent choice because it's
very easy to work I mean any day even in
a small room so it was a very silly
excellent selection of occurrence do you
do you think that working in isolation
was actually beneficial do you think it
allowed you to see things I believe you
saw because a difficulty gave a
possibility we were to use it to the
best was do you have a capacity I mean I
had no problem I will not afraid a
persecution it was no persecution like
in Germany but it was unpleasant
environment you know even if the face is
the many of my schoolmate orso's it came
to see me I mean it was not a
periodicity division with yours
you